Jessica Alba has just arrived she's
greeted by Jessica Alba when she comes
into the Vanity Fair Oscar party so that
feels pretty good that's a good morning
there's no good morning eyes lips face
Jess eyes look face student give me face
look amazing tell me about this look
tonight
um it's Versace and it's very sparkly it
is what do you think of being not only
you know an actress and now an
entrepreneur businesswoman but a creator
of tik-tok you know fan bases around the
world now like you're so cool you're
extra cool scene phone my tech-talk we
have seen the tik toks but we're
actually building our entire style
section on ET tomorrow after eyes lips
face just give us the faith faith I
don't know I just
and everyone is doing it now you know I
really learned from my 11 year old
tic-tock not gonna lie she gives me all
the tips do you have a favorite film
this year oh wow I really liked just one
while you were in the car they just one
for screenplay I mean the phenomenal
screenplay and the acting I mean the
actors were how cool is it to arrive at
the party and be greeted by yourself
have a great night thank you so much
[Music]